the Americans are stepping up to help
their neighbors vladimir duthiers joins
us once again from his house to let us
know how others are helping out glad I
love these kind of stories that shows
humanity humanity is alive and well I
like it
kindness people doing kindness to others
Gail that's what it's all about in times
of uncertainty like this and of course
as the coronavirus has created a new
uncertainty around people's health their
jobs and even their next meal people
everywhere are taking actions both big
and small to help as many as they can
including Steph Curry in the Bay Area he
and his wife Aisha are partnering with
the food bank in Oakland their goal is
to raise funds for at least 1 million
meals for Oakland School District
students now that schools have closed
Gail this is such a great story and it's
so cool to see Steph and his wife doing
this we've seen stories like this
happening all across the country
Netflix executive Wade Davis I saw a
tweet over the weekend that he
essentially launched out there asking
folks who were in need to hit him up on
his DMS and that he would provide them
with some cash from his venmo account
until he reached his limit I actually
spoke to him last night take a listen to
what he had to tell me I was thinking
about how many of the folks who are the
most marginal lives who will be being
impacted right there the folks who are
cashiers who are waiters right like who
do the the hand-to-hand style jobs and I
was thinking that a lot of them probably
don't have the same types of benefits as
someone like myself does so if I can
give 50 bucks a hundred bucks you know I
would do as much as I can as often as I
could you know Gail I mean I you know
it's easy for us to be at home I guess
in some levels because we have the jobs
that we have and for other people who
have the privilege to be able to work
from home it's wonderful but the service
industry medical professionals teachers
those are the folks he was talking about
it was really wonderful
alright let thanks so much